- [Mark] Okay, Levi.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Levi, where
are you from originally?
- [Levi] Orange County, Huntington Beach.
- [Mark] So Orange County out here?
- [Levi] Yeah.
- [Mark] How long you
been here on Skid Row?
- About five, six years now.
- [Mark] Five, six years.
Do you have family?
- No, my mom just passed
away 10 years ago,
and my last known relative, my uncle,
passed away two years ago.
So if they're out there, I don't know.
It's just me, no kids, no wife, no...
- [Mark] Tell me about your
childhood, what was it like?
- Childhood was good, I think.
My mom raised five kids
on a waitress' salary.
They were all older than me.
I grew up by myself in the house,
my mom did whatever she
could, you know what I mean?
I lived with my mom
until I was 14 years old.
And then I walked in one
day, coming home from school,
and my stepdad was drunk,
was in the garage beating
the shit out of my mom and...
Well, I went away for a
long time for that one.
But, yeah, I've been here for awhile.
- [Mark] And you live here on Skid Row?
- Yeah.
- Where are you?
- Fifth and Broadway.
- So you're in a tent?
- Cardboard.
- Cardboard?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Do you have a
girlfriend, anything like that?
- No, just me.
- No?
- Me and my bike.
- [Mark] You and your bike?
Very cool bike.
- Yeah, thank you.
- Love your bike.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] What's your
drug of choice down here?
- Spice right now.
- Spice?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And you've
done the other ones too?
- Yeah.
- Heroin?
- Yeah, I've tried heroin.
I'm afraid of it
because I'm too much of a drug addict.
My hustle ain't, I just panhandle, so.
Heroin's too expensive for me.
Crystal, just run around the streets,
going nowhere, so I smoke spice.
It's cheaper than weed.
- [Mark] So you make money by panhandling?
- Panhandling. Recycling.
I recycle in the morning
and then I panhandle in the afternoon.
Come here and eat dinner
and that's it, I'm done.
- [Mark] Where do you eat?
- Usually the Midnight.
Or someone, I'll be panhandling
sitting by a chicken place
or someone will buy me some food.
But if that don't happen
I'll come down here
to the Midnight.
Ain't too safe at
nighttime, but it's okay.
- [Mark] So, do you sell as well?
- No, I don't sell, no.
- You don't sell.
So tell me about sleeping here.
Do you sleep here at night?
- [Levi] I used to sleep right here
until somebody decided to wake me up
with a bright yellow crowbar
at four o'clock in the morning.
- [Mark] A what?
- [Levi] A bright yellow crowbar.
Yeah, some Cuban dude was drunk
he tried to wake me up at
four o'clock in the morning,
right here on 6th and Los
Angeles with a crowbar.
Luckily he dropped the crowbar
so I was able to get the better him,
so I don't sleep down
past Los Angeles no more
I'm up towards Broadway and
Fifth by Rite Aid and stuff.
In a little doorway so
the manager's cool with me
as long as I clean up my mess and stuff.
- [Mark] You've seen some
crazy stuff, I'm sure.
- [Levi] Yeah, it's
okay to sleep by people
then it's not okay, you never know
when you're gonna wake up.
So I sleep next to a little
68-year-old woman right
now in a wheelchair.
(sirens blaring)
So she does her thing
during the day and then the nighttime
we both go in our little cubby hole.
And I get up, put her in her
in the chair in the morning
and she does her thing.
Down this way it could be dangerous, yeah.
- [Mark] How old were you
when you started drugs?
- [Levi] I was 13 years old.
- 13.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What drug was that?
- [Levi] My first drug was
a slam of methamphetamines
from my girlfriend.
14 years old.
And then weed and all that.
- [Mark] Have you ever been clean?
- [Levi] In prison.
- [Mark] What were you in prison for?
- I was in prison for manslaughter
when I was 14 to 21 years old.
And then I've been to federal prison
for manufacturing counterfeit
securities and explosives.
- Wow.
- But I've been off now
for five years, no probation,
no parole, nothing.
- [Mark] What manslaughter?
Tell me about that.
- That's when I walked home, 14 years old,
and I found my step dad
beating the shit out of my mom.
My mom was unconscious, she
was bleeding in the corner.
I was on my way to baseball
practice so I had my bat,
and I fucking hit my step
dad 38 times in the head
just so he'd stop hitting my mama.
I killed him.
- Wow.
- They gave me juvenile life.
Juvenile life for 14 to 21 years old.
- [Mark] That's justified.
Wow, that's heavy.
Are you an only child?
- I got two step brothers
and two step sisters
but they were all older than
me, when I was growing up.
They were out of the house.
- [Mark] You were basically an only child.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
Thank you for sharing that.
Where do you want to see
yourself in five years?
- Gone.
- [Mark] Gone?
You have no hope for
anything brighter or? No?
- I don't know.
Just survive another day, you know?
- [Mark] Yeah, it's hard here.
Thank you for talking with me.
- [Levi] Thank you.
- [Mark] Good luck with everything, man.